Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number
and that number is 2192. David P,
our friend, the egg man called
in. He's starting to think maybe
there really is a deep state. Listen to this.
Speaker 2: Hey, guys. Is there legitimately a
deep state? Hmm? Okay. Think about it. Just
recently, Joe Rogan and Alex Jones both are
starting coming out for DeSantis on their radio
shows, on his radio programs that are national,
that have this right wing leaning, that have very
low IQ listeners and low IQ speakers. Which are
all starting to pop up. The fact is, defense is
all over. Is somebody controlling that is leading
that? That's a Republican deep state. That's
a right wing deep state. There's more evidence
of that. No, there's no. I made it up, but
there's more evidence of that in a Democrat deep
state. Why don't the Dems say, who's controlling
all this media? Who's causing the media to flip
from Trump to the Santos? Yeah, somebody is
controlling. This is a right wing, deep state.
Who is it? Whose hand is on the button? I think
the Dems need to change the way we talk about
this stuff. There's something going on. Or
maybe there's not. I don't know. Problem.
Speaker 1: All right. Shalom to the egg,
man. Yet the egg is completely right. I mean,
just like, imagine a different scenario, okay?
Imagine the scenario, the real world right now,
which is Joe Biden's the president. And again, we
don't know if Joe Biden's running for reelection.
We just don't know right now. Imagine if all of a
sudden every left wing show you turn on this show
and I'm talking about, you know, just whoever
just makes them like Hillary Clinton. Like
this is actually is the perfect example.
Imagine that you turn on The David Pakman Show
and I am for some reason talking about how I think
it's over for Biden and we need to get Hillary to
be the 24 nominee. And then you turn on MSNBC and
they're saying it's time for Hillary to come back
and you turn on Thom Hartmann and Tom saying,
we've got to draft Hillary Clinton or whatever.
Of course, these right wingers would immediately
say this is evidence of the deep state. Somehow,
even though Biden's president you are seeing a
coordinated and calculated effort to rehabilitate
and resuscitate Hillary Clinton's political career
to make her the 2024 nominee. It's the Bilderberg,
it's the Trilateral Commission, it's the
Illuminati, it's the, you know, whatever,
whatever you want to say, it might get
worse, it might get anti-Semitic as well.
And yet it's actually true that from somewhere
there is a movement coming that is starting to
question Donald Trump's place at the top of the
Republican Party and question Trump's assumed 2024
nomination if he wants it. And they're starting to
talk about Ron DeSantis. They're not talking about
anybody else. They're not talking about Nikki
Haley. They're not talking about Lindsey Graham
or, you know, whoever they're talking about, Ron
DeSantis. And the reason that the left doesn't go,
it's a deep state conspiracy. It's because
it's absurd. It's absurd. What's going on is
there are lots of people who never like Trump,
and there's still a significant number of people
in the Republican Party who publicly go along
with Trump. This doesn't make them good people,
by the way. They publicly go along with Trump
because they saw the way the tide was turning
and they see the way the winds are blowing now
for now still. But they would rather someone
else. They believe that Trump has been damaging
to the party and so they'd rather someone else.
And right now that someone else most pointedly
seems to be Ron DeSantis. That's it. We we don't
go to Deep State because there's no evidence of
that. And of course, it would be the same thing
if all of a sudden the left started uniting around
someone else, even though Biden's the president.
But the right would immediately say it's a
conspiracy, it's a deep state. You're taking your
direction from Soros or whoever else is
going to be very, very good point by the man.
We have a fantastic bonus show for you today. We
now have polling. Do Americans support canceling
student debt? A majority do. Now, that doesn't
mean that that's the reason to do it. Most people,
if you go to them and you say, hey, would you like
your loans paid off, who's going to say no if you
come to me and you say, Hey, do you want me to
pay off some garbage? Sure, I guess. Pay it off.
We don't do things necessarily just because
people want it done. But it is interesting that a
majority of voters support this political decision
made by Joe Biden and that may have a political
impact. We will discuss. There is a there's
a drought happening in much of the country.
In California. There are a water bans, drought
restrictions that have been put in place. And a
whole bunch of different celebrities are accused
of just violating it. They are flouting it,
not flaunting, flouting. You can look that up.
Kim Kardashian, Sylvester Stallone and others.
We are going to talk about the legal realities
of such water bans on the bonus show. And also,
I do want to update you about what's going on
with Donald Trump's platform. Truth, social.
Speaker 2: Growth, essential.
Speaker 1: Massive financial problems.
Much like Trump with his own lawyers not
paying a number of different vendors,
the days may already be numbered for
troth central. And I have to tell you,
it would just be delightful if the free market
decided that the platform is trashed and it's
trash and it deserves to be flushed. That would
be an absolutely delightful thing. So I would love
for you to join us on the bonus show today.
Speaker 3: Oh, the bonus show where you
want to make money. Everybody else that
makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: Yeah. You're invited to join us
on the bonus show. You can sign up at join
Packman dot com and you have the added benefit.
If you were to sign up today that Wednesday,
we're doing our next members only townhall it
will be an exclusive event to participate in
for our members. Anybody can watch. It will be
streaming live on YouTube, Twitter and Facebook.
But if you want to participate in the town hall,
you sign up at join Packman dot com and of course
you can use the coupon code. Obama. Obama to
get a discount. All right. Sign up. We will
see you on the bonus show. And I look forward
to seeing you on the town hall on Wednesday.